joining me now a south african native
lara logan host of fox nations lara
logan has no agenda
alar a lot of americans aren't really
aware of what's happening right now in
south africa i've traveled there i've
been lucky enough to travel there many
times
um and i've seen this kind of
deterioration over the last
really 10 or 12 years since i first or
maybe longer 15 years since i've been
going there
um what do we need to know about this
well many south africans are just
shocked at the speed with which this is
spreading
laura and it's worst in two provinces
one of them is the home province of the
former president jacob zuma
and um i've been speaking to people
there food is running low this has been
going on for five days
and the stores are burning down there's
no milk
there's no bread and people are not
allowed to
have any fuel for their cars so this is
a particularly
distressing situation for many many
people there with so many
killed at this point and people are
asking where is the police where is the
army and while they are going to
deploy more soldiers there are very
worrying reports now of this becoming of
a racial element being introduced
into this there's a an indian community
that live
uh just outside of durban where jacob
zuma is from
and um there have been a number of
reports um that are fanning the flames
of
racial tension and violence there and
what you start to see
is some of the echoes of you know
critical waste
theory and the woke agenda that have uh
proliferated all over the world
we're paying the price now for big tech
and facebook and all these people
who are able to really set the agenda in
any country that they want
and where people can spread this message
and spread this divisive politics
and south africa is no exception so
there's a marxist element
at play here in other words
well you know obama's ambassador to
south africa was a man called patrick
gaspard
and when obama's term ended and he came
home he became the president of the open
society foundation
george soros's foundation yeah and i
know
and but when he was in south africa he
was very vocal about reparations
he was one of the people who was pushing
and encouraging publicly
for the south african government to take
land away from white people
particularly white farmers of course 30
000
white farms in south africa feed those
people
and they feed other people across
southern africa and so when you take
that land away and it's not used
to farm anymore you starve your people
people saw that in
neighboring zimbabwe so there is a
radical element at play here and nobody
can tell
at this point it's impossible to say how
much this is involved
but south african media is very quickly
turned to looking at who's driving this
and whether there is uh there are other
forces and
you know there are eerily similar echoes
here there's a whole ideology that goes
along with open society and all these
affinity groups
about turning a moment into a mass
movement or a revolution
and that's what many people i speak to
are looking for laura thank you for that
we're not going to hear that anywhere
else tonight hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else